hmm oh my God yo what the hell did you
do I'm playing with ketchup
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys where we are currently
on the record time
what the [__] is that ugly the record
was that uglier it was a little bit ugly
I said on the record I didn't like it I
just feel like he pointed at me for sure
I don't know about the rest sorry well I
saw him go like this I went yeah so I
thought it was coordinating something it
was a hosting you guys kind of jumped in
on it yeah oh it wasn't for us but I
took it anyway if you're in host chat
you get it if you're not you don't get
it I just feel like you guys just don't
ruin it you're not in the Discord enough
to understand exactly so it doesn't even
know how to use Discord anyways move on
Bart just learned how to use Discord I'm
still learning I don't even know that
says a lot of fees if he's willing to
learn it just for the fans that's a big
thing what a layup thank you you got to
go in there and say GM by the way you
got to say GM every day GM what's jam
mean good morning oh I was like and then
you got to say say it back you gotta you
gotta say it back GM sirs here's here's
the question of the day
when is a time that you actually said no
to sex
all the time every [__] day of my
life would be because it's like
sometimes you're tired do I mean and
then sometimes you
um have a have a schedule
I know about schedules yeah
you just go but in this case let's say
it's not someone that you regularly have
sex with it's a person you've never had
sex with and you've rejected them I
never had that you've never had that I
did that but I didn't know what the [__]
was going on what happened what's going
on I've talked about this before but I
was in I was in school actually a draw
in the drama area
and you know it's a big [__]
Auditorium so I got pulled into a dark
area with a chick who wanted to like
probably blow me or something and she
was like grabbing my dick and I was just
like haha and I laughed and I like
walked out of there and I I just didn't
know what the [__] was going on but you
were not into her it's not that I wasn't
into her it's just I didn't know what
the hell was going on and she was like
grabbing on me and that was like pretty
early into my experiences and stuff he
was a adolescent okay a man yet I was
like six years old
so well it was after a handball
no I was like I was I was in I was in
high school I was a freshman
it was definitely very forward move by
her
um she was a senior
it was cool and stuff and she had boobs
and I should have done something about
it but I was stupid
I just got nervous didn't know what's
going on yeah mine was with Geo actually
the first time that so yeah so um you
turned her down so when we first no not
because of that why'd you raise your
hand then uh when we first so
in our group we had a uh our group of
friends Geo was with my best friend at
the time and so when they were together
um she ended up hanging out with the
group the group just became friends and
then slowly like people changed changing
the group and we kind of like lost touch
and uh I wasn't best friends with that
dude anymore and she still stayed in the
group and we ended up liking each other
and so
um we started hanging out and then there
was a time where we were doing the kissy
kisses and then when it got to that part
I just felt I felt so bad I was like I
need to clear like even though I'm not
best friends with that dude anymore
because that's been like three years one
of those this is all wrong so forbidden
that would have made me horny I need to
clear this [__] up I need to clear this
[__] up how far to get did you already
have a boner though let's be real oh for
sure Dick's so hot but the hot feel
wrong man yeah so I had to clear it up
with him that's see that's more credit
to that if the Dick's already hard and
then you turn it no but also your friend
though yeah you still broke the broker I
know I did technically I did he broke
the broker he's a broker violator yeah
but is it bro code if he's not your bro
anymore I mean what's up bro Alyssa bro
I don't know it kind of is it bro but
where you guys a bro at that time no oh
yeah I thought because if it was like
Romeo Juliet and she's from like the
Rival enemy family then you could get
all up in that [__] you know if it's
for the Rival family yeah so you had
more of a feeling of we showed it more
than she did right because I think the
bro code is a bro thing yeah I think was
she like hey [__] put it in that's a
really good deal by the way yeah thank
you do you know how many other [__]
Bros have been in here
no this is again a good deal no I just
felt it just felt like I don't have to
clear [__] up you know so I ended up
meeting up with them and then I told
them everything they talked talked it
out you respected the other person
because it's like it's I I think it's
like [__] in a poor like public
bathroom you can't really [__] your
heart out like your home's toilet so
then you need to clear out everything
because it just feels like Perfect
Analogy it feels like this level of like
it the whole way through even though
it's really fun it just feels like
there's like I don't know there's
something I can't do it 100 I need
approval before I [__] it's like laying
down in a public restroom kind of weird
like yeah practicing breaking moves yeah
in a public bathroom in a McDonald's
restroom yeah here's a weird one um
there's this girl that I was gonna hook
up with and uh great girl hope she
doesn't see this
what's your name first and last
when uh she took her clothes she took
her dress off she had
um
this device
it was like belted around her with like
a box
and I'd like a colonoscopy back and she
didn't explain what it was immediately I
don't know so I got kind of like what
the hell is that and I and I kind of
decided not to do it why wouldn't she
explain right away did you have a moment
with yourself like wow I'm not [__]
Batman so it's probably shouldn't be
here
a utility bill with a breath a yellow
utility belt with a bat on the front and
smoke bombs on the side she told me
later but that's not fair what's in the
belt so I guess I guess it's like a
diabetes oh diabetes oh but she wasn't
like overweight like she so there's no
grappling hook or anything no it just
looks like a Walkman you really don't
want to lose
it's just like a thick um like belt
thing and then there's I think it's like
connected to her
like she was able to just take it off
but it's like one of those weird things
where someone doesn't say anything and
you're like in the throes of passion and
you just put it aside where were we yeah
hey hold on what was that was it
connected to her pancreas I don't know
what it was wait so so in the in the
thousands of passion she did take it off
nonchalantly but you took everything
else off but then you left that [__] on
you're like I don't know what if she
drops dead or something I don't know
it was just on my mind too much oh so
you're like wait a minute
[Laughter]
yeah yeah there's a loose screw inside
it's like
and you're like bro what is that on your
phone mechanical thing how did you exit
from that situation I did I silently
just stopped do I didn't verbally say
like hey let's stop like I just stopped
physically oh and then she kind of just
stopped too and then we're just like
let's go back to talking we kind I think
I kind of just navigated to others it
was stupid it was really bad like it was
very obvious that I got self-conscious
so she we were both trying to avoid it a
little bit and then later when she got
more comfortable she she was like saying
it was for her blood sugar or something
did you guys end up doing it after no I
didn't it just kind of ruined what
happened yeah I felt really like rude
because it's just like it's one of the
singer you don't know you know like um
you just don't know how you would react
but then uh because I wasn't expecting
anything I I just was like why am I
thinking of it so much stop stop I guess
I'm just one of those guys who's so
straight and who's so down to [__] that
I just I just want to play out there you
know I am not that straight I guess
I'm so like
concerned about her feelings that I just
be like oh I better pretend because then
she's gonna really be scarred
emotionally yeah I think that's what I
should have done but again like I
probably would have said that's what I
would do but then when you're not you
don't even know it's there and suddenly
you see it that's like hmm but it's good
on you you didn't go ill that yeah
that's definitely the first reaction
that most people what is that yeah I
still don't 100 know exactly how it
works or what it is but I know there's
probably a lot of people out there that
wear something like that I have a friend
who has that oh really yeah but for his
heart like it's literally outside of his
body his heart's outside of his body
yeah so you squeeze it like this
no his heart is not us but he has a
machine outside of his thing I think
it's for like um yeah I don't know what
is it like a circular like a pacemaker I
don't know like a different like a
defibrillator pacemaker I don't know
what it is but it's like outside is it
my father-in-law has has some [__] like
that did it have a grappling hook yes
that's all you want to know every time
it's his fault man under something now
it's so cool to have one of those you
know yeah so that's that's one time that
I that I said no to it and I regret
navigating it that way dude when you're
a married person and you have access to
sex all the time it's like pretty
awesome first of all but then but then
you want it to be
you know like like if I'm not gonna if
I'm like dude I'm [__] my body's [__]
physically exhausted I'm just like yo I
am [__] wiped out or same thing I
think he's like oh well you know I she's
like I just [__] I'm tilted in poker
right now I can't [__] you know like
[__] like that it's just like it just
becomes that's one thing I noticed the
older you get and the more you've been
with the person the more you want the
conditions to be perfect because you
[__] in better conditions yes so
you're like
oh like in high school you could be
stuffed into the back seat of a car you
didn't shower because you guys went
camping where you don't give up that's
true behind a pizza place dude yeah but
now you're like can we both shower first
and then you know the showering's nice
it's just so like it's everything yeah
you're like now you know how good it
could be so you kind of just want fine
dining every time versus like nasty Taco
Bell sets not even worth it and yet the
nasty ones when it does randomly happen
sometimes a little passionate ones
that's true that's true but then
sometimes you're like us I don't know
why Taco Bell's so yucky now
when we were in Mexico and I was
stepping on Nikki's head that was just
one of those things where I was like I
just got carried away in the moment you
know all that tequila and that was in
the morning no that was in the morning
the day after did you say stepping I was
stepping on the back of her neck with
one leg stepping on her head with the
other leg just making sure making sure
she's down did you insert at any point
throughout this is jacking off dude I
was just beating off over her back
but that's Steve by the way I'm glad you
met him yeah but sometimes you feel like
sometimes jerking off is uh just a
little bit better sometimes that's a
dangerous slope I still do balls I do
sex I jacked off last night different
what a thing to brag about
did she watch you did she watch you yeah
she's sick right now is that why she's
like we can't [__] tonight you gotta do
your thing and I'm like okay and she
just sits there looking at you no she
just feels she feels the earthquake in
the bed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah she feels like Indiana Jones
sometimes she'll go up to the beach like
what are you watching and [__] cup my
balls while she's watching does she
really yeah why doesn't she just Jack
you often she does sometimes because I'm
like oh none of these pornos are working
she goes fine dude one time she [__]
was looking at Instagram and I'm like oh
who's that Fitness influencer she goes
is she hot and then I'm like oh she got
a nice booty she goes I know huh and I'm
like but she got a butter face and then
so she put it on her butt picture put
the phone down and then she jacked me
off while I was looking at her phone and
I was like oh my God
oh my God air high five dude bro let's
go Joe if you just administered VR to
you honestly yeah that's two DVR it's a
beautiful relationships beautiful
kinship that's that's really good I get
a shake because I'm like oh you don't
really get jealous that I look at part
and then she goes no I like watching
porn too and I'm all like but then like
I don't want you to judge me for the
type of porn I like sometimes so I just
look at the straight stuff Have you ever
showed her a type of porn you like and
she actually got disturbed by that like
you're like I just want to show you my
vampire hentai but I don't
but I do no everything's always been
like cool I'm more I think she's more
open than I am yeah yeah is her pornos
crazier than yours she does I don't
think she really watches porn and that's
like fireman [__] or something no her
I think her um yeah acceptance and like
just what she's okay with is like way
bigger that makes sense because UK
people are culturally just it's not that
big [__] the porn in real life she chose
a Japanese dude like dude that's already
crazy and they had they had new they
have nudity on TV over there right yeah
they do I mean they don't give a [__]
man and that's honestly so good for kids
too because it doesn't make sexist keep
away [__] that we all do yeah and then
you end up doing crazier worst [__]
under wraps in order to maintain an
image to the public yeah that's true
that is a bad byproduct that's a hugely
bad byproduct but that's what that's
Americana baby right that's what we do
because we shame you because of the
church and [__] and we just make you
feel bad about it and then like when
your chicks in high school like that's
why there's always a girl who's doing
hardcore anal and she's always the most
Christian person too always always it's
always it's so weird but it's just how
it goes I guess deep shame leads to Deep
deeper-ish
deep throat that too if you're lucky
that's good and daddy issues you're in a
very healthy thing that's cool
yeah I think so but do you but when you
if she jerks you off do you sometimes go
well let me do it because this speed is
different
yeah but I don't want to offend her oh
definitely because I'm all like ah that
hurt oh like I just I just okay thank
you wait do you actually give her
directions yeah dude that's like an
Asian backseat driver yeah I'm like oh
to the right oh okay do you also make
the noises that you make when you talk
about jacking off here where you go
I always picture him yeah
I got a picture Bart 20 years ago
walking outside Joe's house and hearing
he's like I'm gonna wait ten is there a
party going on I'm jacking off
he was telling us earlier about you
being a weirdo like he went over to your
place
and he heard like a bunch of [__]
music and then you're just like in there
talking to yourself huh yeah
um back when he used to live on orange
when we first started hanging out I
remember I went over to your place and I
heard like at least four voices
and then when you opened the door it was
just you inside I was like oh [__] hey
what was I doing I don't know I don't
know what you're doing no no so you had
to just stand like
he was probably either making beats or
on a forum or watching TV at all at the
same time well you're rehearsing dinner
while making dinner rehearsing lines
before he was on YouTube before he was
doing anything
organic vlogger man I don't even
remember
we know
story where you declined the hookup for
any reason Anthony
no one else Anthony
you're talking about first times yeah
uh have you ever reject somebody that
because they don't look as good that as
you want like you came to your senses
and you're like what am I doing good
Lord to be completely honest the only
time I can actually no not really
because I don't think that I would put
myself in that situation if I felt like
I was unattracted to them oh okay but
even after the Brewers come up to you
that would be the only time I I've only
probably rejected sex when like I knew
that person was drunk to a point that it
was like I don't know if that's for sure
no that's what I'm going uh that's true
because I have experienced the other
right where it's like drunk and then
like it's like regretful the next day
and it's like dang I didn't want to be a
part of that for your your experience
you know what I mean so like later on
it's like same thing it's like if things
are moving that direction and then
they're just a little sloppy it's like
uh it's all good dude do you guys ever
get okay admission time
I don't I am not into chicks with
accents at all I'm not into it all of
them all of them interesting so they
have to speak proper English American
even someone with one as sexy as a
Filipino accent uh
why don't you want to [__] me it feels
like that kind of in a dumb way like I'm
maybe exploiting someone somehow what
yeah is it like a white guilt even if
it's like British or Australian or what
if it's a redneck
like even wider than you oh like a
southern belle what about like what
about a bayou princess what is that
Canadian
I don't hear it yeah
I think I'd just be like well Texas a
Texas country girl
I mean that doesn't bother me it's I'm
talking like if it's like if it seems
like holy Steven you got a big donor if
it's like if it seems a little sus to me
in any way like talking about the drunk
thing right yeah like it seems sucks to
me in any way I just get too weirded out
like if you feel like you have a edge on
this situation yes like if if I feel
like they are maybe being sex trafficked
in some way or some [__] oh like a
passport bro yeah because I watched too
many [__] movies and TV shows and
[__] I'm like I don't know I just get I
just get freaked the [__] out oh my God
yo what the hell did you do I'm playing
with ketchup Oh I thought you were
breeding the camera
don't do this guys I thought it was
bleeding I'm talking about and I'm
talking about just like meeting someone
and like [__] them not like you're
talking dirty right now Joe busted a nut
dude
oh my God no I'm wearing white a little
close for you to be playing ketchup dude
I'm wearing all white hair dude
I currently I remember in uh in high
school you know in high school people
just play stupid [__] games all the
time so like uh like oh you talk to her
you talk about that kind of thing right
so we're all hanging out at our friend's
house and there's like a bunch of people
over and then one one of my friends told
me that there's a chick that thought I
was cute and I was all cool and I looked
at her she was cute and then uh then he
told me
um that she was down to [__] that night
oh and I was like that's a strong jump
well I thought you were high school
games right like oh she'll [__] blow
you in the closet or whatever you're
like I was just like high school games
yeah I was like oh [__] what the [__] I
was like this is kind of crazy and then
I was like has she been drinking and
then she was been drinking a little bit
so I'm like well I don't know kind of
like in your shoes right because you're
like she doesn't love me for me and then
so I was like no no I was like but what
if I match her so I started pounding
beers like crazy that's fair that's the
most Bart solution it's a good
hypothesis she's like I'll match her and
then and then and then you know in high
school if any if anything's about to go
down everyone is so up for it don't be
like there's two people going upstairs
they're gonna [__] and everyone's down
just like yeah
because it happens so rarely right and
then um I was like okay so I started
pounding away and I'm on my face about
to explode from [__] Asian glow and
I'm like
I still can't
wow good boy we ended up getting
together after
but I just I just still just couldn't do
it and then I asked her when we're
together I was like were you really down
to [__] me that night she was like yeah
she was like [__] dudes like like the
first night before I was like oh [__]
she's like I'm [__] a dude right dude
[__] me right now
dude's [__] me right now
damn yeah she was gangster as [__] but I
was like well that's the thing though is
like very little guys can experience one
night stands and then but girls that are
just down to do it they can experience
it yeah it's like the balance is
completely different it's way different
like I've said before I did a one-night
stand once and it was like miserable for
me because I'm such a [__] [__] that
like I needed to make an emotional
connection like up almost like in the
spot after like you created a narrative
I created a narrative and I [__] like
yeah I was like in this thing for like a
month and I was like Wow trying to make
it work I went and sorry and it just I
wasn't connected with her at all and it
was weird
and then I had to it's not you it's me
thing and like it does [__] with your
mind though because every single time
I've had a one night stand it always I'm
in disbelief even after
it happens I mean I'm just sitting there
like damn how did that happen it always
feels like it's too good to be true yeah
well and it's a curse too because like I
said the guys that I when I watched
movies and TV shows that they can just
like meet a chick [__] and move on but
I'm like I'm like oh I I need to justify
this what I did okay someday will be
like fresh and fit
that's so [__] cool
I know to really dedicate ourselves
sometimes I disagree with women voting
I know
right I'm trying to build
from here anyway